foreign
and welcome back to another video by
simply learn this is anubhav and in this
video we will be creating a angularjs
project but before we jump to the coding
part if you haven't subscribed to our
Channel already make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and press the Bell icon
so you will never miss any update from
Simply learn so without further Ado
let's see how our application will look
like at the end of this video
so let me show you however application
will look like
so
like this our application will look like
here you can add anything like like
share
and comment
you can also remove it or Mark as done
like this you just have to click
and just remove if you want
from here you can just write anything
and just add like this if it's done
or you want to remove it
so
before we jump to the coding part let me
just tell you about a angular overview
so what is angular angular is an open
source JavaScript framework written in
typescript
Google maintains it and its primarily
purpose is to develop single page
applications as a framework
angular has clear advantage while also
providing the standard structure for
developers on a team to work with it
enables users to develop large
application in a maintainable manner
so there are so many advantages
using angular but the two I love the
most is data binding and browser
compatibility
you can also check out our videos on
angular for deep understanding
so what is data binding angular enables
users to effortlessly move data from
JavaScript code to view and react to
user and events without having to write
any code manually
and the browser compatibility as angular
is a cross-platform and compatible with
multiple browsers an angular application
can typically run on any browsers for
example Chrome Firefox and others such
as Windows Mac OS and Linux
so
let's open our
Visual Studio code
let's cut this
first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna create an angular project
for that let's open our command prompt
in this command prompt we'll write a
command
npm
install
I think globally
at
angular
CLI
press enter
so for this you must have node.js and
npm install in your system
it'll take a couple of seconds to
install the files let's wait a minute
meanwhile
let me tell you why we use angular
JavaScript is the most commonly used
client-side scripting language it is
written in HTML documents to enable
interaction with web pages in many
unique ways as it is relatively easy to
learn language it is well suited for
Developers for modern applications
let's wait a couple of seconds more
so whatever angular application is
installed
so now we're gonna create a project for
that
we're gonna write NG new and the project
name
here I'm gonna write
angular
ah
press enter
we're gonna ask you a few steps
yes I'm gonna type CSS
and it will install all the necessary
packages
let's wait a couple of seconds more
let's discuss some other things about
angular
JavaScript idle for developing single
page application that we all know but
that requires modularity testability and
developers probability perhaps not
these days we have a variety of
Frameworks and libraries designed to
provide alternative Solutions
with respect to where front-end
Frameworks
angular addresses many if not all of the
issues developer face when using
JavaScript on its own so angular is the
best app or tool to develop applications
so angular is the one thing I love the
most
so let's wait more seconds
so
all the packages are installed
successfully
so now
let's now open our Visual Studio code
let's cut this
and inside this let's open our folder
you can check the path of the file where
you have installed this so in my system
it's in the user
yeah
and angular wrap is here so I'm gonna
open it
so
this is what
it will open
most of the code we are going to do is
in this source file
so we're going to open this app
so let's delete this we're gonna not
need it and
or application
we don't need routing as well
and
now
let's open style.css
let's
delete this
and let's write some Global styling
here
let's write margin
if it does zero
bad thing zero
Order Box
and
fun family
let's save this file
and let's open index.html
so here it's
angular app
now let's just run this and see how it's
looking for that let's type control and
backtech
to open the terminal
or you can also go here
let me just first
zoom out a little
then new terminal
inside this
new terminal
I'm gonna write
in this earth open
let me show you
so we're gonna type
yes
enter
let's wait a couple of seconds
so as it's saying
this can't compiled
so let me see the issue here
it's saying
most of the times the
app routing the file that I have deleted
so because this file is has been called
somewhere
because of this this error is coming
so I'm gonna go here
and see where this file is
called
so we're gonna remove this part
this
app routing module part
now let's save it
now
let's see where are the issues here
again
do the compiling
until it's being compiled
we're gonna see if
where are the
HDM file the CSS component is empty
in this HTML only
the issue is coming so it must be in the
last of this yeah
let's remove this save this file
and as you can see it's compiled
successfully
we're gonna go again to a Wrangler
application
as you can see it's showing this store
to
create a new component we're gonna write
this command NG generate component and
the file or the project name
angular material for that we're gonna
write this command
and like this there are so many other
commands also
if you want to learn angular you can
just click on that and it will open the
angular Iota tutorial part
so we don't need that let's delete this
and the application that we have created
let's delete it also
let's minimize this
and let's work on our code
minimize this as well
you don't need components
so let's delete this file
let's delete this
and here we'll write app
it's
there
I'll use a twin tag
and inside this I'm gonna write
from
simply done
let's save it and see on our browser
it's saying hello from simple
isn't it amazing
let's write here
angular
to do
app
let's just save it
let's say angular to do up
now
let's make it under editor
let's write this one
between this so we'll make this
under header
it's working fine
no
I'll create a component for that
I'll create
a new terminal in here I'll write
a command Ng
globally
component
components in that I'll write
two two
enter
so as you can see here
component inside this app
has been created under to do
so here as you can see
so many to do components and TS file has
been created a typescript file
so everything looks good here we don't
need this file so we're gonna remove it
so
let's minimize this
and inside the components folder
HTML
let's delete it
and create a class
to do
inside this class
I'm gonna create another class
let's name it as to do
let's make this as to do's
and this has two
after that
I'll create a class of
ID
so that we can
fetch the numbers
as for the junk data I'll write zero
like that
we'll write F class
content whatever we're gonna post inside
that
so I'm going to write content
and inside this I'm going to write
my
two two
after that
I need it there now we can create a
button
of class
delete
and then inside that I'm gonna write
oh
it's fine let's see in the browser
how it's looking
wait a couple of seconds
and then read a code
so
first we're gonna call it inside this
okay
that's right amp
tutus
it's not fit
[Music]
let me see
tool okay
let's first see in the modules that
should provide that two two component is
automatically as you can see here
the 2do component is automatically has
been imported in this
see the issue
let's first see the component name
inside this file
okay the component is app.22
that's why it's not fetching
let's
delete head now save it
compiled successfully zero my to do and
remove button
let's move forward now
so this is fine but we need to Loop this
how many times
so because of that
we can't write it so many times for that
we're gonna do
create a array inside this to do
component
under this Constructor
now we can use
angular
engine for that I'm gonna write title
here I'm gonna write
two two
not component
let's see
so let's save this file in will go back
to our
to do a company dot HTML and inside this
we're gonna call this class
so the name of the class here is title
that's why
I'm calling this here
let's see
you will see to do
if we'll change this to
to app now let's save this
it will show us to do app
okay so this is how we can inject our
variables inside the Dom
so now
let's
delete it
to
tools
let's add here
now let's save this
let's compile
Ireland satisfied only
title
so we have created an area
so let's create a file because we don't
want to access it from here so we
create a file let's name it as
to do
well let's
models first
let's just create a folder first
inside these models
will create a file
you
to
dot screen
inside this we'll explore class
to do
yeah well
if the content
but
freeing
and
it'll get completed
we'll get cool
so
as you can see here
and then
and
so guys oh
sign
it's looking fine now let's save this
file
let's move forward
let's first import
you do
we'll import this module
to dot TS file
so let's end this
2-2
from
take
modules one two
this is the path of this
so let's
see
save this
we have to write
doodle array
components are done
so we will
this is a keyword so
this
array
exit this
here I will write content
let's
it's true
complete
completed
okay it's
content
what we are going to show so it's
will come under
okay
first content
and here we'll write
true
so it's fine
we'll create two so we'll copy it from
here
paste it under there
it looks
let's save this the error is coming
can't fetch it so I guess the
reason behind it is
it's switching in
yeah
let's save this still
compilation error is coming
deleted
let's try similar only
we're gonna have to work on our codes
let's minimize this
now
here we'll call it function
attribute for the asterisk
equals to
let
to do
it
goes
and then let
I equals to
index
and they can become the hairs so this
looks
fine save it
so
it can't fit it so you know
as the index here
it's not fitting
oh
okay we have declared here
as I as index so we're gonna write I
let's save it quite successfully
one okay fine
before we go deeper into the code
I'm gonna copy the CSS file
from here
let's copy this
and we're gonna paste it
component part
there are just simple CSS commands
we'll get this code in the description
box
let's save this
let's cut this
is not fetched
C
oh
mistake
these CSS should come under
total company.css let's save this
save and cut this also on this
now we'll open a gram so our application
is going to look like this
is
buttons are not functional right now but
we'll make it functional
so let's
let's style it
remove will remain the same because it
is coming under the button part
now we're gonna call methods
and the methods are like just functions
okay
no
index
at
to do
it complete
when it will get complete
then Mark as done
otherwise
empty
so
it's done
it's completed
okay
let's see this
now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna make
method or function
so that whenever we click on this part
will just get cut or Mark as done
Sudan
I'm gonna go to this to the component
and under this
I'm going to create a method
done
and I'm gonna pass the ID
and inside this
this
dot map
don't worry I'm gonna tell you
how this is working and what I'm doing
it's not fetching V and I
just wait
where I'm gonna write
see
if
I is equals to equals to ID
then
P Dot
P did
we'll get cut
or equals to
not V
Dot
dot completed
or if not
then return
V
so what I'm gonna do here is
okay this is
left
I'm gonna pass the number here
by the number
inside this ID
things look
normal
let's find the issue here what's the
issue
okay
we have declared V and I but we can't
fetch it because it's under this only
so to
access this V and I here also
okay
check this let's
see
it's second and it's coming like this
let's go back to our code
and make it as
only
let's make this also
this both are coming like this
okay
let's
The Click function
side
and side over
component
EML okay
here only
clear click whenever we click on any
item
I'll pass through dog
see
and here we're gonna pass
inside toggle hi so I will call this
will pass through I
save this
here also in the delete path
we're gonna do it later let's save it
first
see
whenever we click on this
LDL leader
like this
fine
let's just
go back to our code
after this we're going to create a
delete method
let's name it as delete
total
this will implement
inside remove
like
so to delete
we will not write
again this to do
this
equals to
this
Dot to do
filter method
I will call B
B
again
stem will not repeat
old mistake
run right
not equals to
2 by D
when I is not equals to ID remove it
this is a function
so
we're going to call it like
we call inside our toggle done so we're
going to save this
going back to our code
after this right click
when I will click
it will call
it
to do
and inside this will pass index
save this
coming back to our
component
let's just
create bar
add to function
so let's first declare here
giving her number is
whenever will
put the number only that time it will
work
so we can't add a string here so that's
why we are declaring here
number
let's just delete this from now
save it and see
the remote function is also working now
going back to our code
what we'll need is
remove or ADD
so now we'll work on
let's let's create
first thing we're gonna do is
inside this
dot HTML
so we're not writing
to
help create a class
there
class name
and inside this
let's try create a form
set this form will create input from the
user
so what
he or she wants to enter in this
or first thing we'll need is the text
next we need is the name
and put
to
after that please holder
inside that box that will get created
all right
enter
your
after that you get the class
of
of
input
to do
I have declared here as to do
input
no your hand
let's
one thing I'm forgetting is the
in the model
will get red because
we are not
so this is coming red because we haven't
created this input to do
the component so we're gonna create it
right now only
first here first let's just save this
okay
and let's
delete
okay
let's just delete this save this
it's coming red okay
let's
to do
is a string of
declaring
what
will come under the string is
a Boolean only or not Boolean string
value only
let's open this
here
I'm gonna import
huh
Ng
module
triangular
code I guess
only module is already
fetched so we're gonna need
only
import
ant
forms
module
angular
oh
let's see this
hold it inside our
side over
app module
see yes
here we're gonna write
this module
with this app.euver
even
um
this
save as
so
I've called this one
so it's working now
this still is not working let's delete
this so everything is working fine now
there is no
nothing
and you can add
it's not adding
now everything is done
you cannot see it
and inside this we will call this Dot
doodles
dot push it
content which will come under this will
be content
whatever comes under this
and two two
and then completed
then false
let's close this
and after this
let's create the empty string here
called
to do let's run this
I have here looking for
hello
from
another click on let's mark it as done
we can also remove it
yeah and we can also add it
like
share
if this is Mark as done
click here as done
okay
so with this we have reached the end of
this tutorial thank you for watching and
please subscribe to our Channel stay
tuned to Simply learn thank you
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here